[Musique]
une volonté profonde avec christian
jacob avec aurélien pradié avec toute la
nouvelle équipe dirigeante de refonder
avec humilité la droite française je
suis les républicains et que je ne suis
pas née la petite option emmanuel macron
ni la petite option marine le pen
emmanuel macron jouent ce jeu cynique je
les dis des grands discours mais pas de
réformes profondes
une méconnaissance absolue de la valeur
du travail de la laïcité des territoires
et de l'écologie positive
ils jouent à la courte échelle avec
madame le pen faisant croire aux
français que c'est lui ou le chaos
attention parce que après lui ce
pourrait être le cas il y a aujourd'hui
la règle dans notre pays qui sont que
tous les lieux qui relève du service
public doivent être neutres et l'école
singulièrement les voyages scolaires moi
j'ai été maire pendant plusieurs années
relève du temps scolaire ce une évidence
les accompagnateurs sont assurés par le
système scolaire est donc dans cet
espace là pour moi il doit y avoir une
neutralité absolue 2004 la loi sur les
signes religieux à l'école 2010 la loi
sur la dissimulation du visage
la ppl ciotti il y à il y à peu en 2014
la circulaire chatel en 2012 donc on ne
peut pas dire que la droite soit
opportuniste sur ces questions elle a
été constante et je trouve que dans le
commentaire de des manuels macron qui
rapportée par par valeur
c'est intéressant de voir qu'une fois
encore il se saisit finalement de cet
épisode pour installer à nouveau le
match avec le seul rassemblement
national feignant d'ignorer que les
sorties possibles
elles sont aussi dans les propositions
des républicains parce que les
républicains considèrent que précisément
pour éviter un embrasement anti islam
il faut pouvoir légiférer clairement sur
ces sujets combler un vide juridique la
république elle est une
dans ces espaces là elle doit s'affirmer
et la vraie faiblesse c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la république ne dépasse
plus les individualités au moment où
l'islam radical est en train de tester
la république nous voulons poser des
limites
[Musique]